as honeymoon periods go this has to be
one of the shortest in political history
less than a month since Liz trust took
over as the UK's new conservative prime
minister her government's controversial
tax and borrowing plans mean the
conservative party conference is
literally besieged by critics
from the PM and admission
I do stand by the package we announced
and I stand by the by the fact that we
announced it quickly because we had to
act but I do accept we should have laid
the ground better I do accept that
the economic strategy of trust and her
Chancellor is intended to dramatically
boost growth with a plan to give tax
cuts to the rich funded by billions of
pounds of government borrowing sent the
currency and bond markets into turmoil
last week and members of truss's own
parliamentary party are threatening to
vote against it
people need to feel and need to see
that
when we are making the case for tax cuts
that the people who benefit first are
those who are those who have leased
to coincide with the first day of
conference several thousand campaign
groups and union members converged on
Birmingham city center if you want to
preserve your hospital your care center
for the elderly top of their concerns is
the fear that the government will start
cutting public sector budgets
people have got to be ready for an
avalanche of cuts in everything that
they experience in public life just
going about their business and we've got
to turn that around that is a direct
attack on working-class communities
let's just spoke about there being too
much focus on Optics in politics too
much on how things look but that ignores
the reality of politics and that is to
get things done you need support support
of your MPS in Parliament support of the
people in The Wider country and at the
moment and it's just appears to have
neither guaranteed
after 12 years in power the conservative
party's become accustomed to its annual
conference being a rather comfortable
and controlled Affair this year is
shaping up to be very different Paul
Brennan Al Jazeera Birmingham